buongiorno abate barriere il cuore
perché è la passione che ci guida come
matematici la matematica per il cuore
perché voglio convincere v che la
matematica è anche utile per noi per la
nostra salute perché perché le malattie
del sistema cardiocircolatorio sono
molto importanti riescono a impattare in
termini mortali il 45 per cento della
popolazione ai paesi ricchi nei paesi
occidentali con un costo economico in
corso sociale straordinariamente grande
si stima che siano circa 200 miliardi di
euro per anno artisti sistemi che stia
questo l'impatto sull'economia di un
continente come l'europa
eppure eppure la 80 per cento circa
delle malattie delle nostre sistema
cardiovascolare sono in qualche modo
preventivabile questo è il ruolo e
questo è il punto in cui ama tema di poi
inserirsi questa è la nicchia di
intervento della matematica
vogliamo utilizzare la matematica per
cercare di aiutare i medici i clinici a
meglio comprendere il nostro sistema
cardiocircolatorio e si è possibile a
meglio curare persone che sono affette
da patologie e anche eventualmente
meglio progettare interventi gli unici
che siano più efficaci per pressione che
ne abbiano bisogno il cuore ha
sostanzialmente quattro camere due altri
due ventricoli il sangue venoso entra
dalla vena cava viene poi spedito ai
polmoni dove viene ossigenato ritorno
attraverso le vene polmonari nell'atrio
sinistro e poi attraverso la valvola
mitrale entra nel ventricolo sinistro e
da qui attraverso la val orti ca
entra nel nostro sistema circolatori
globali attraverso l'arteria porta un
sistema estremamente complesso richiede
un singolo perfetto ci sono grandi le
formazioni grandi spostamenti una grande
pressione di una contrazione a
dilatazione del nostro del nostro cuore
ci sono i valori che si aprono e si
chiudono in maniera molto rapida e
esattamente grazie a questo sincronismo
che il cuore può funzionare così come
funziona
quello che vedete un cuore vero questa è
una pulsazione vera è un'immagine presa
ovviamente in tempo reale
rendete conto effettivamente di quanto
complesso sia il meccanismo di
funzionamento
la potenza che esprime il cuore
straordinaria potete farvi un'idea
pensando a se avete mai fatto un
esperimento di questo tipo alla
compressione di un pallino da tennis e
la forza che ci vuole il lavoro che
dovete produrre per schiacciare una
prima da tennis bene questo è
confrontabile in termini dimensionali al
lavoro che il cuore fa in ogni secondo
per permettere a questa capita a questa
struttura che quasi completamente cava
di spedire il sangue il nostro sistema
circolatorio
si stima che nell'arco di un ciclo di
vita
il cuore riesca a mandare nel nostro
sistema circolatorio l'equivalente di un
milione e mezzo di barili di sangue
quindi una sforza è veramente titanico
ed è una scintilla che cita la vita in
ogni secondo è una scintilla è un
pacemaker naturale che parte dal seno
dal nodo seno atriale e si diffonde poi
attraverso un sistema complesso di fibre
le cosiddette fiber al pur kingi
nell'impero miocardio ogni cellula del
nostro miocardio viene coinvolta viene
attivata
questo dà luogo per un complesso
meccanismo biochimico ad una contrazione
oppure dilatazione di queste cellule e
l'effetto aggregato di questa
contrazione dilatazione e quello che
determina poi la contrazione o la
dilatazione del sistema cardiaco in in
senso lato
perché dovremmo fidarci della matematica
per un problema così complesso perché la
matematica ci aiuta a ragionare
la matematica ci aiuta a sviluppare
quelle che oggi si chiama il
ragionamento computazionale ovvero
affrontare un problema nella sua
complessità a partiziona ndaw lo in
sotto problemi
ognuno con una sua logica intrinseca ma
ogni sotto prima collegato agli altri
sette problemi
queste capacità di sintesi queste
capacità di aggregazione concettuale
quello che fa della matematica uno
strumento assolutamente potente e vorrei
dire unico dobbiamo quindi essere capaci
di descrivere diverse macchine che
agiscono in sincronia nel cuore la
macchina elettrofisiologica quindi
quello il modello che descrive la
propagazione della del potenziale
elettrico nel nostro sistema
poi la macchina biochimica quella che
determina poi il funzionamento di ogni
singola cellula la sua polari
stazione di polarizzazione poi la
macchina meccanica perché c'è un effetto
deformativo come abbiamo visto la
macchina fluidodinamica perché abbiamo
naturalmente il sangue che è un fluido
dentro le nostre cavità e poi infine
l'attivazione delle valvole la dinamica
valvolare allora tutte queste macchine
in realtà sono dei modelli matematici
che convivono scambi di informazioni fra
di loro
ed è esattamente la risoluzione di
questo problema che è dal punto di vista
matematico una mostruosità assoluta è
molto complesso stranamente complesso
tradotto in equazioni che traducono i
principi fisici fondamentali della
nostra vita e alla risoluzione di questo
problema dicevo che ci permetterà di
descrivere la funzione cardiaca e anche
la disfunzione cardiaca
non c'è nessun umano nessun matrimonio
incapace di risolvere questo problema è
troppo complesso sordina mente complesso
abbiamo visione della mediazione di
regolatori abbiamo bisogno di tradurlo
alfinito di approssimare lo renderlo
fruibile al calcolatore attraverso degli
algoritmi molto complesse attraverso
linguaggi di programmazione e sarà poi
calcolatore che ci aiuterà a trovare una
risposta e quindi a rappresentare questa
realtà virtuale che descrive il
funzionamento del nostro cuore
questo è il problema dobbiamo risolvere
la simulazione è l'elemento fondamentale
quindi partire dal problema esatto che
non sappiamo risolvere tar duri non
poneva riso il libro sul calcolatore e
poi effettuare la simulazione del
comportamento capirlo
ovviamente il paziente è l'attore
fondamentale in questo discorso
l'individuo abbiamo bisogno di acquisire
dati i dati vengono acquisiti dalle
indagini della risonanza magnetica per
esempio ma la cosa importante riuscire a
passare da questa rappresentazione che è
una rappresentazione percezione di come
vedete ad un modello geometrico completo
come questo questo è il primo passo
secondo passo è quello di tradurre
questo modello geometrico conna degli
elementi geometrici molto piccoli
gli elementi di una ipotetica griglia di
calcolo
alla fine del processo saremo capaci di
descrivere la soluzione in ogni elemento
di questa griglia quanti ne so quanti
sono necessari dipende dalla accuratezza
un milione 10 milioni 100 milioni a
volte un miliardo bene arriveremo a
risolvere problemi di un miliardo di
equazioni per descrive il comportamento
umano
queste sono le fibre del muscolo
cardiaco
che queste riprodotte con un algoritmo
matematico perché difficilmente rivelata
rilevabili in termini di risonanza
magnetica ritmo grafia assiale questa è
già la simulazione questi sono già dei
buoni matematici qui vedete ladri o
sinistro e là c'è un fronte che avanza e
del fronte del potenziale elettrico ci
sono colori diversi il rosso è il
massimo ogni colore ogni intensità di
colore indica l'intensità del fenomeno
quindi la quantità di potenziale in
questo caso specifico bene stiamo
descrivendo come in un cuore sano il
potenziale vede così propagherà il
nostro filo sinistro qui stiamo
descrivendo con un ventricolo sano si
deforma in tempo reale adesso vedete la
velocità vera qui è soltanto decelerata
per far vedere meglio questa è la
velocità vera di pulsazione cardiaca a
sinistra viviamo nella immagine laterale
a destra mi dà un'immagine dall'alto
capite come ad ogni stati il nostro
cuore si contragga dal punto di vista
della della dalla sua lunghezza di circa
il 30 per cento si dilati ancora di una
percentuale del calo del 25 per cento e
poi di e luogo di una torsione
assolutamente straordinaria e questo
movimento incredibile per certi aspetti
molto poco naturale molto poco ovvio
molto poco lineare che fa sì che il
cuore abbia questo tipo di rendimento
quello che vedete è un cuore vero di una
persona vera sono due ventricoli che
vedete dall'alto adesso li vediamo
decelerati quindi rallentati quello il
potenziale cardiaco il potenziale
elettrico si sta propagando nel nei
ventricoli questo un cuore malato un
cuore che ha una patologia che si chiama
l bbb è sostanzialmente un blocco di una
parte del del miocardio dovuta per
esempio ad un infarto
è evidente che la propagazione come se
fosse un onda che incontra un ostacolo
viene deviata si da luogo delle
variazioni a delle come dire interazioni
di onde è come si sviluppasse un
movimento sostanzialmente caotico
ovviamente fuori di questo tipo vanno
curati e la matematica per aiutare a
capire come intervenire con quali tipi
di relazioni da fare in modo che poi
queste onde anomale vengono ricondotte
nel loro alveo di comportamento di
comportamento naturale
questo è un cuore sano questa è una
simulazione che vi fa capire come il
flusso di sangue si comporti nel nostro
cuore
in alto vedete la trio sinistro in basso
vedete il ventricolo sinistro il sangue
arriva dalle quattro vene polmonari il
sangue ossigenato entrano all'altro
sinistro si da luogo in una dinamica
piuttosto complesse nell'altro sinistro
quando la pressione del sangue supera la
pressione di resistenza della valvola
mitrale questa valvola si apre questo
sangue entra nel ventricolo sinistro in
basso
ovviamente va a gonfiare ad amplificare
il ventricolo sinistro quando questa
pressione ancora è superiore a quella
esercitata dell'arteria porta la valvola
aortica si apre il sangue viene espulso
e viene mandato nel nostro sistema
circolatorio bene capite che è un
movimento molto complesso
non c'è nessuna indagine radiologica
risonanza magnetica demografia che possa
rappresentare il movimento in questo con
questo tipo di realismo ma vorrei dire
soprattutto in questo tipo di significa
il significato quantitativo questi sono
non è solo un'indagine qualitativa è
un'indagine quantitativa
questo è lo stesso tipo di simulazione
qui vediamo la formazione delle
strutture vorticose e non è esattamente
turbolento il fluido che il flusso che
si sviluppa nel cuore ma è quasi
turbolento dal luogo di una vorticità
che assolutamente straordinaria e grazie
a questa vorticità che non abbiamo
nessuna zona di stagnazione nel nostro
veicolo e grazie a questo fatto che i
nostri menti col è strano puliti e che
il sangue si comporta e il nostro cuore
continua a comportarsi in maniera
straordinariamente efficace questa è
un'altra simulazione ancora verità
l'apertura della valvola aortica
sono i tre lembi i tre foglietti da
valvola orti che si chiudono e si aprano
permette ovviamente al sangue di
fuoriuscire entrare nella orta
ascendente che quella che vedete che
quella che vedete in alto
queste sono simulazioni straordina mente
efficaci dal punto di vista della
qualità del risultato
c'erano anche simulazioni straordina
mente complesse per darvi un'idea
qualitativa un secondo di vita reale
quindi un battito cardiaco che prende
circa un secondo richiede su un gloss
calcolatore diciamo il più grandi che
con la tour europeo circa una settimana
di tempo di calcolo delicato perché
tutto questo perché la matematica ci sta
dietro alla tematica estremamente
potente estremamente raffinata e perché
la nostra vita e una vita complessa
molto ricca il cuore ha un funzionamento
straordinariamente complesso da
catturare
l'algoritmo matematiche utilizziamo è
capace di darci in ogni millesimo di
secondo
quindi mille volte prelibate lo cardia
con l'evoluzione complete del fenomeno
cardiaco siamo tutti differenti ognuno
di noi è un cuore diverso ad ogni altra
persona
non solo ma diciamo ha tempi diversi
momenti diversi il nostro cuore si
comporti in maniera differente come
tener conto di questa variabilità
beh questa è una delle cose molto
difficili dobbiamo tener conto di come
la variabilità tanti cuori versi è
condizionata dalla forma che ovviamente
diversa dalla dei dati biologici quindi
ad esempio dalla viscosità e densità del
nostro sangue diverso da un paziente di
una persona all'altra dalla
distribuzione delle fibre del miocardio
ancora pinna che variano in una in una
in spazi e dimensione infinita
sostanzialmente e poi dei dati
funzionali cioè la la nostra diciamo
stato di salute in quel preciso istante
può mettere il conto in più da questa
variabilità da queste una grandissima
sfida per noi matematici e questo il
nostro sogno il sogno è quello di una
medicina passion specifica ovvero
vorremmo essere in grado domani di a
produrre questi risultati per ogni
singola persona e se possibile in tempo
reale che significa tempo reale in un
tempo che sia abbordabile che sia adatto
e conveniente per l'analisi del medico
in corsia
per fare questo bisogna mettere in piedi
un modo di ragionare ma tema di
completamente differente da quello
tradizionale
quindi esplorare una grandissima varietà
di pazienti o di persone quelle che
vedete rappresentate in alto per ognuno
di questi a fare queste simulazioni
straordinariamente accurate con i
supercalcolatori mettere via in database
ricchissimo tutte queste simulazioni e
poi quando arriva un nuovo soggetto
esplorare e approfittare e sfruttarli
maniera conveniente le simulazioni di
prima in modo tale da rendere alla
simulazione per quello specifico
soggetto molto agile molto rapida e
fattibile e addirittura su uno
smartphone
possa essere utilizzato in tempo reale
dal medico questo è il nostro obiettivo
questo il nostro sogno ma non siamo io
penso troppo lontani dalla possibilità
di realizzarlo allora vorrei concludere
dandovi un messaggio a questo è un tipo
di matematica quello che sviluppiamo per
il sistema cardiocircolatorio ma per la
medicina in senso lato io ho parlato di
questa applicazione ma naturalmente si
può cercare di generalizzare è ultimo
nella tematica accurata e quantitativa
quindi complementi in maniera perfetta
la conoscenza clinica che è ovviamente
molto basata sulla conoscenza e
l'esperienza sull'arte del medico e
sulla diciamo esperienza vissuta questa
è anche naturalmente sulle immagini
radiologiche sono immagini che
permettono dipende dalle foto istantanee
e sono delle foto che mi aveva visto
prima di particolari specifici per
esempio delle sezioni del sistema
cardiocircolatorio è una matematica
accurata l'accuratezza e nelle mani del
matematico abbiamo la possibilità di
decidere con quale accuratezza fornire i
risultati
questo è un controllo del sistema che ha
fatto ovviamente grazie alla matematica
è una matematica non invasiva e questo
importantissimo non abbiamo bisogno di
sottomettere il paziente ha altre
indagini
quindi non è invasiva non è intrusiva e
una matematica virtuale è un approccio
di rituale è fatto con carta e penna e
computer naturalmente ma nei laboratori
nei laboratori scientifici quindi non
abbiamo bisogno di acquisire nuove
indagini e quindi ovviamente essere più
di impatto dal punto di vista personale
dal punto di vista sociale ed economico
sul paziente è una matematica predittiva
non voglio soltanto capire cosa sta
succedendo in quel momento a quella
persona
voglio pensare di poter prevedere cosa
succederà a quella persona nel futuro
quindi voglio fare la simulazione
esattamente come quando faccio le brevi
nel tempo voglio capire oggi come sarà
il tempo domani e dopodomani
vorrei poter usare questi modelli per
capire come l'evoluzione di un paziente
in particolare se un certo tipo di
patologia si svilupperà in una certa
maniera o in un'altra maniera
questo tipo di sguardo in avanti ancora
una volta è una caratteristica
assolutamente fondamentale che la mafia
maria garantisce
è una matematica vorrebbe essere come ho
detto prima piscine specifica quindi
vorremmo domani essere capaci di dire è
questo il cuore di questa esplicita
persona questo cuore specifico si
comporti si comporti si comporterà
esattamente in questa maniera
questo è un sogno ma lavoriamo per
questo e infine vorrei dire che una
matematica sostanzialmente a costo zero
perché naturalmente c'è l'investimento
della conoscenza dalla ricerca
dell'intelligenza
ma poi a questo punto da poter
utilizzare in maniera sostanzialmente
gratuita questo credo che sia il
messaggio importante una volta i greci
pensavano che nell'antichità il cuore
fosse lo scrigno dei nostri sentimenti a
questo è corroborato in qualche modo e
qualche evidenza sì abbiamo una forte
emozione positiva la prima volta che ci
innamoriamo abbiamo certamente un cuore
che agisce manier estremamente vitale
sembra una emozione molto negativa
parliamo di cuore spezzato e questo
effettivamente si può tradurre a volte
in una liberazione di ormoni tali da
distribuirsi pone sistema cardio
circolatoria e quindi avere un impatto
non è ancora chiaro sul comportamento
del cuore
noi siamo ancora a questi livelli di
capire come coniugare emozioni
sentimenti passioni e comportamento
fisiologico e patologico del cuore con
la matematica
siamo però già vicini a poter descrivere
l'azione e la disfunzione cardiaca in
termini estremamente precisi
[Applauso]